EDWARDS.
EARLIER TODAY HE CHATTED AT
RISING STARS PRACTICE WITH CHRIS
HAINES.
>> THANKS, ADAM.
ANTHONY, LOOK, I KNOW YOU'RE A
PRIDEFUL GUY, MAN.
NUMBER ONE PICK, IN THE RISING
STARS GAME BY TEAM ISIAH.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR YOU?
>> I WAS THE NUMBER ONE PICK.
>> YOU WERE THE NUMBER ONE PICK?
>> NO, FOR SURE.
THAT'S LOVE.
IT'S A BLESSING, SURE.
>> BEING IN THIS EXPERIENCE,
SEEING THIS, IT'S COLD OUT HERE.
I KNOW YOU'RE IN MINNESOTA, AND
SO YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT USED TO
THIS.
WHAT'S BEEN YOUR EXPERIENCE THUS
FAR IN CLEVELAND?
>> I'VE BEEN IN THE HOTEL ROOM
THE WHOLE TIME, MAN, FOR SURE.
BUT, I MEAN, SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE, IT'S ALL LOVE, OPEN ARMS,
SHOWING GOOD LOVE, YES.
>> THIS IS NOT YOUR REGULAR
PRACTICE, A TIE HERE IS THIS
BECAUSE OF THE COLD WEATHER?
>> IT'S COLD IN HERE, MAN, IT'S
FREEZING.
WE'VE GOT TO GET SOME HEAT ON,
GET SOME FANS IN HERE, YOU KNOW.
GET SOME HEAT.
IT'S COLD IN HERE, MAN.
>> ONE THING I'VE GOT TO ASK
YOU, WE'VE GOT TO GET TO THIS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE MOST HIGH
FLYING DUNKERS THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS LEAGUE, POSTER RISING GUYS
ALL THE TIME.
WHEN ARE WE, OR ARE WE EVER
GOING TO SEE YOU PARTICIPATE IN
A SLAM DUNK CONTEST?
>> NO, MAN.
I'M AN IN-GAME DUNKER.
I DON'T HAVE DUNKS LIKE, IN MY
BAG LIKE THAT, FOR LIKE TRICKS.
I'M NOT REALLY A BIG TRICK GUY.
I JUST LIKE TO DUNK ON PEOPLE.
>> YOU CAN DEFINITELY PUT
SOMEBODY IN THE PAINT.
>> OH, MAN, IT'S -- I FEEL LIKE
THE DUNK CONTEST IS TRICKS.
PEOPLE WHO CAN GO UP THERE AND
SPIN.
I CAN'T DO ALL OF THAT I WANT TO
DUNK ON SOMEBODY.
>> LAST THING REAL QUICK.
YOUR TEAM LOOKS PRETTY STACKED.
HOW DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU LOOK IN
THE FIELD RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK WE HAVE EVERYTHING WE
NEED.
TWO OF THE BEST THREE-POINT
SHOOTERS IN THE LEAGUE.
A FORCE OF FIV